[Musique]
il y a véritablement un problème
d'insécurité qui est dû à une
immigration qui est beaucoup trop
importante le général colonisation le
général de Gaulle disait
la mixité oui à partir du moment où elle
est contrôlée elle est contrôler et à
les gérer si vous voulez bon ce n'est
plus le cas voilà ce n'est plus le cas
on est submergé maintenant effectivement
[Musique]
on est là pour affirmer que la Bretagne
a toujours été une terre d'accueil et
que ça c'est toujours bien passé en fait
il y a pas eu le souci il n'a pas eu de
il a pas eu de tension jusqu'ici et en
fait c'est eux qui créent les tensions
c'est les gens qui refusent cette
affaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous avez
la fâcheuse sphère qui se rassemble à
Callac
des Gilbert Collard etc
c'est une petite ville de 1200 habitants
qui accueille déjà une cinquantaine de
réfugiés et un chiffre à vous donner
aujourd'hui il y a zéro pour cent
d'incivilités liées aux réfugiés
[Musique]
il y a eu la pollution car il y a eu
énormément d'intoxes dire à des
grands-mères qui avons été gorgés violés
dans la rue à cause de l'arrivée des
réfugiés vous voyez voilà on est dans de
la désinformation dans faire régner un
climat peur c'est absolument écœurant de
voir ça
[Musique]